[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter les théories de christophe
guilluy un géographe à qui on doit
notamment le concept de france
périphérique dont on entend beaucoup
parler en ce moment depuis le mouvement
des gilet jaune
les tests de guy lui en trois dimensions
sociales géographiques et socio ethnique
et sont habituellement invoqué en france
lors des périodes électorales car ils
permettent d'expliquer la répartition
géographique des votes
tout d'abord il a analysé la répartition
de la pauvreté et des classes populaires
en france
en france la question de la pauvreté et
de l'exclusion des classes populaires
est fortement liée à la question des
banlieues et cités des quartiers appelez
les comme vous voulez et qui est elle
même fortement liée à la question de
l'immigration
si bien qu'on l'ait naturellement
pauvreté immigration et quartiers
sensibles
même si c'est un non dit qui lui montre
que la pauvreté ne s'y trouve pas
exclusivement et qu'elle est aussi très
présente dans d'autres zones notamment
dans le rural et c'est logique
en france il ya 8 9 millions de
personnes qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
les quartiers prioritaires de la ville
abrite 4 8 millions de personnes dont 42
pour cent vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
donc les trois quarts des pauvres n'y
vivent pas de plus qui lui va
relativiser le discours victimaire sur
ses banlieues
loin d'être laid zone de relégation
décrit par les discours politiques
particulièrement à gauche ce sont des
quartiers où l'on investit massivement
de l'argent public que ce soit pour la
rénovation ou pour l'insertion des
habitants qui ont un taux d'équipement
public important et qui de plus se
trouvent souvent dans des bassins
d'emplois dynamiques ces territoires
bénéficient aussi d'une forme de
discrimination positive
par exemple pour l'entrée dans certaines
écoles comme sciences po ou des jeunes
deux aides peuvent entrer sans passer le
concours avec macro on peut aussi
ajouter le dédoublement des classes et
le petit déjeuner gratuit pour les
enfants en primaire par bien des aspects
les habitants de ces banlieues sont
mieux lotis que les classes populaires
en milieu rural qui sont éloignés des
grands bassins d'emploi et des services
publics
alors pourquoi cette fixation du
discours politique sur la misère des
banlieues pour guy lui il s'agit d'une
dérive liée à l'introduction d'une
grille de lecture américaine le ghetto
noir dont les banlieues françaises sont
perçus comme étant un décalque en termes
de problèmes sociaux et de
discrimination ethnique
résultat de cette grille de lecture on
est menés 6 et le social serait pauvre
tout ce qui vit en cité et est d'origine
immigrée et parallèlement serait de
classes moyennes tout ce qui est blanc
et n'y vit pas guy lui va ensuite
expliqué les dynamiques démographiques
économiques territoriales et pour cela à
distinguer deux grands types de zones
les métropoles grandes villes
tertiarisée profitant de la
mondialisation et la france périphérique
grosso modo il considère qu'il ya autour
de 25 métropole en france sa grille de
lecture ce n'est donc pas la ville
contre la campagne comme on pourrait le
croire
socialement les métropoles ont tendance
à se polariser aux extrêmes est
schématiquement on retrouve les classes
supérieures
les csp + et les plus pauvres surtout
d'origine immigrée dans les cités il ya
aussi une polarisation au niveau de
l'emploi avec des emplois très qualifiés
d'un côté et de l'autre des emplois très
peu qualifiés surtout dans les services
après tout il faut bien des nounous et
des caissières pour servir les csp + les
classes intermédiaires elles ont
tendance à disparaître
la région parisienne est la caricature
de cette métropole cette polarisation
s'explique par deux phénomènes
d'abord le renchérissement du coût du
logement dans les cartes et
intermédiaires par l'arrivée des classes
favorisées en sociologie on appelle ça
la gentrification les classes moyennes
inférieures et populaire voulant se
loger dans le parc privé aussi bien
comme locataire que comme propriétaire
puis de plus en plus loin de la
métropole pour trouver un logement à
prix décent on peut aussi apporter une
explication complémentaire à savoir la
fuite des classes populaires des zones
urbaines pouvant les accueillir à cause
du sentiment d'insécurité culturel cette
insécurité culturel est due à la
proportion de plus en plus importante
des immigrés qui fait que la population
française ne se sent plus chez elle dans
ces territoires
quand on est pauvre et qu'on ne se sent
plus chez soi en banlieue on va à la
campagne
aux usa ce phénomène de départ des
blancs pour des raisons ethniques porte
un nom ça s'appelle le white flight la
france périphérique elle
géographiquement est constitué du
périurbain et des zones rurales mais
aussi des villes moyennes et socialement
il ya une prédominance des classes
populaires et moyennes
notamment celle fuyant la métropole pour
diverses raisons cette france
périphérique on peut il vivre et où il
travaillait et économiquement elle est
en perte de vitesse
l'emploi qui s'y trouve est à l'opposé
de celui de la métropole veut de travail
hautement qualifiés un emploi industriel
et des activités anciennes et artisanale
ça c'est pour le volet théorique mais
derrière cette analyse sociaux et non
géographiques les tests de guînes mi
homme de gauche sont aussi politiques
et à vrai dire de plus en plus politique
au fil des ouvrages il faut dire qu'il
est chercheur indépendant et qu'il n'a
donc pas à retenir ses coups pour lui la
situation actuelle de partition
territoriale sociale et ethnique est le
résultat de la mondialisation libérale
les élites les classes favorisées ceux
qui bénéficient de cette mondialisation
l'ont intégré comme horizon indépassable
et donc considèrent qu'elle ne peut rien
au niveau économique
si ce n'est accompagné le système vers
plus de dérégulation condamnant au
passage au déclassement tout un pan des
classes moyennes aux emplois aujourd'hui
inadapté à ce système socialement
polarisée en conséquence la gauche a
abandonné son électorat historique les
classes populaires pour un nouveau plus
porteur celui des banlieues en déployant
un discours victimaire et multiculturel
et par les classes moyennes supérieures
les bobos en dérivant vers un discours
sociétal
le tout est entré en phase avec le
libéralisme ambiant et on ne peut pas
complètement donné tort à guilluy
cette stratégie visant à unifier les
électorats bénéficiant d'une façon ou
d'une autre de la mondialisation a été
théorisé en france il ya quelques années
par le think tank social-libéral terra
nova
je ne sais pas si vous vous en rappelez
mais terra nova avait pondu une note
disant clairement il fallait abandonner
la classe ouvrière pour se concentrer
sur deux électorats les immigrés et les
bobos c'est à dire l'électorat fortement
présente dans les métropoles
du coup avec de telles critiques n'est
pas en odeur de sainteté à gauche où
cette aide sont mal acceptée voire
combattu il faut dire que politiquement
il allie a7s géographique des éléments
souverainiste et protectionniste peu en
vogue dans cette partie de l'échiquier
politique
je me rappelle d'un article de libé tout
fier d'annoncer qu'une note de lindsay
contredisait les théories de guy lui
sauf qu'en fait pas du tout la note de
l'insee montraient qu'il y avait une
forte pauvreté dans les métropoles
ce qui n'est pas contraire à ses idées
ça montrait surtout le manque de
connaissance ou la mauvaise foi du
journal résultat des courses
paradoxalement malgré le côté marxisme
géographique de cette théorie une partie
de la droite a été plus réceptive à
cette théorisation d'une france d'en bas
blanche que la gauche et on dit que ses
premiers écrits ou influencer nicolas
sarkozy en 2012
bref son analyse de géographie sociale
se transforme progressivement en
critique du libéralisme de la
mondialisation et de la gauche sociale
libérale alors qu'en penser sa notion de
france périphérique décrié par certains
chercheurs est elle valide
il s'agit d'un outil méthodologique qui
réduit le réel pour pouvoir
l'interpréter outils réducteur que
toutes disciplines et tous courants
intellectuels utilise y compris ces
chercheurs qui d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
innocent sont souvent politisé à gauche
il faut bien le dire ces tests fournisse
une explication cohérente au moins pour
la partie technique aux résultats
électoraux en 2017 la france des
métropoles a largement voté macron
champion de la start-up bichonne et de
la mondialisation heureuse et la france
périphérique assure voter marine le pen
on peut également supposer que cette
france périphérique a été sur
représentés dans le mouvement des gilet
jaune mais je pense que les thèses de
guillon du succès notamment à droite
pour d'autres raisons que leur
adéquation avec les résultats électoraux
ou que leurs critiques de la gauche
elles permettent d'aborder la question
de l'immigration cette altérité ethnique
que l'on voit apparaître et grandir et
du ressenti des populations d'accueil en
fournissant des explications
rationalisant tu ce qui permet d'évoquer
ces sujets sans trop se prendre deux
noms déplaisant en pleine figure
bref à chacun de juger de la pertinence
de cette thèse personnellement je les
trouve extrêmement intéressante et si
c'est également votre cas et bien
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo est
sur ce je vous dis portez vous bien et à
la prochaine
[Musique]